hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar impacting
patient outcomes with rapid positive
blood culture id
utilizing maldi mass spectrometry
i am tracy aston martin of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
broker daltonix learn more
visit brooker.com i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation also
please notice you can share this webinar
on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today speaker mr ike
northern
ike is the director of infectious
disease testing and
immunology at compunet clinical lab in
dayton ohio
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen ike you may
now begin your presentation
i would like to thank you for joining
today to discuss the use of the broker
multitask sepsi diaper
the learning objectives for today's talk
include an explanation of the clinical
presentation of sepsis
and the importance of laboratory testing
we will also describe the advantages of
using rapid diagnostic tests
on positive blood cultures and discuss
current technologies
used for rapid identification then i
will outline the experience with
root card septic typer that we have had
lastly we will review
a couple of patient cases where sepsi
typer was used to identify the isolate
in a blood
culture and the impact it had on patient
care
copynet is a regional laboratory that
services five hospitals
two standalone emergency rooms and
hundreds of doctors offices
microbiology testing for hospitals is
consolidated into one location
our laboratory has a full service
microbiology lab
that includes all of the major
subspecialty areas such as bacteriology
parasitology psychology aop testing
serology
and molecular testing we have 46
employees in our microbiology department
that work on all three shifts
in addition to 11 employees that work in
serology and the molecular area
blood cultures are drawn at each
hospital site and
are sent to the microbiology lab for
incubation and testing
we do about 5 000 blood cultures per
month
before talking about testing let's do a
review of what sepsis is and its
implication for the patient sepsis is
the body's immune response to an
infection this is caused by a
dysregulated
immune response that can be extreme and
affect multiple systems in the body
in many cases this is a life-threatening
illness according to the cdc
about 1.7 million americans develop
cessus
each year and about 270 000 of them die
about one out of every three patients in
the hospital have sepsis
and is it is the 10th most common cause
of death in the u.s
sepsis can be divided into three
categories depending on the severity
in sepsis the patient will have fever
increased heart rate
rapid breathing and other signs of
infections these patients have a
an 18 mortality rate in severe sepsis
all of the symptoms of sepsis may be
present but the patient will also have
organ dysfunction
and the mortality rate increases to 40
percent
the most severe form of sepsis is septic
shock
these patients have the symptoms that
have already been mentioned
in addition to a drop of their blood
pressure 60 percent of the patients that
develop
septic shock will die
so what is the laboratory's role in
diagnosing and treating sepsis
along with the clinical symptoms there
are a number of lab tests that can be
used to help diagnose sepsis
and increase white blood cell count as
an indicator of infection and
as is an increased monocyte distribution
width an
increase in the lactic acid level is
indicative of organ dysfunction
found in severe sepsis and septic shock
a blood gas can be used to evaluate the
acid-base changes found in sepsis while
procalcitonin helps differentiate
bacterial from viral infections
and it is it is increased during sepsis
blood cultures permit the growth of the
causative agent of sepsis allowing
identification of the organism
and susceptibility testing lastly a
urine culture can help determine if
the sepsis symptoms are caused by
seeding of the bloodstream
with an organism causing a urinary tract
infection
let's talk about blood cultures in more
detail
normally two to three sets of blood
cultures are drawn when sepsis is
suspected
and usually includes both an aerobic and
an anaerobic bottle
within 24 hours about three quarters of
positive blood cultures will
will become positive another 15 to 20
percent will become positive
within 24 to 48 hours the positive
bottle is subcultured and the organism
typically grows
after overnight incubation using
traditional microbiology
techniques the identification of the
organism is completed in 18 to 40 hours
the susceptibility intestine is
completed in 36 to 48 hours after the
culture bottle flags is positive
you can see the list of the most common
organisms that we see in our laboratory
these 10 organisms account for 75
percent of the positive blood cultures
over the past 5 to 10 years there have
been a number of new diagnostic
tests that allow for the rapid
identification
of blood culture isolates so why is this
important when the patient has sepsis
studies have shown that the sooner they
are placed on
the appropriate antibiotic the better
their outcome will be for this reason
patients are that are suspected of
having sepsis are placed on broad
spectrum antibiotics to treat
the causative organism prior to the
blood culture becoming positive
the ability to use rapid identification
methods to get the patient
on the best antibiotic has a number of
advantages there is less exposure to
unneeded antibiotics
which in turn reduces the risk of
resistance development
and other side effects the patients also
have become
have better outcomes with reduced health
care costs
since the broad spectrum antibiotics are
used empirically some patients are
placed on antibiotics that are not
effective against the cause of agent
mortality increases each hour the
patient stays on the wrong antibiotic
rapid diagnostic tests help shorten the
time required to get them on the correct
antibiotic
there are a number of tests on the
market for rapid identification of blood
culture isolates
let's discuss each of these
the first test is the pna fish test by
option
advantix this assay utilizes dna probes
that are tagged with fluorescent
chromophores
a gram stain is performed to determine
which reagent kit to use
and blood from the positive bottle is
placed on the slide the reagent is then
added to the slide and the dna probe
is allowed to bind with the nucleic acid
of the organism in the sample
the reaction takes 20 minutes and the
slide is read by using the fluorescent
microscope
the color of the organism on the slide
is based upon the dna probe
which attached to the organism and
determines the identification
for example in the gram-negative bacilli
kit
there are three dna probes if e coli is
present the organism will stain green
klebsiella pneumonia will stain yellow
while pseudomonas originosa
stains red there are kits for four
separate organism groups including
staphylococci
from negative isoli enterococcus and
candida
biofire manufactures the film array
blood culture identification kit
this is a multiplex pcr test that allows
identification of 26 bacterial targets
and 7 yeast targets
in addition 10 resistance genes are
detected
along with the organism identification
all organisms and resistance genes are
detected using a single cartridge
and this assay an aliquot of the blood
is injected into the cartridge
that is shown in the lower left corner
of this slide this cartridge contains
all the necessary
agents to perform the multiplex pcr the
cartridge is placed in
the instrument and results are available
in about an hour
luminex varigene also produces a
multiplex pcr test
they differ from the biofire and that
there is a separate panel for
gram-positive and gram-negative
organisms
the gram-positive panel detects 13
bacterial targets as well as three
resistance genes
the gram-negative panel detects nine
bacterial targets with six resistance
genes
like the bio-fire assay the blood is
injected into the cartridge and placed
into the instruments
results are available in about two hours
genmark is another company that makes
multiplex pcr assays for blood culture
identification
they have three separate cartridges the
gram positive panel detects 20
bacterial targets and two resistance
genes in addition the
the cartridge contains probes for pan
gram negative
and pan candidate targets allowing you
to to detect mixed infections
or it directs you to the use of another
panel
when the grain stain is questionable the
gram negative panel
detects 21 targets with six resistance
genes it also contains probes for pan
grand positive and pan candidate targets
the third panel is a yeast panel that
contains 15 targets just like the other
multiplex assays
an aliquot blood is taken from the
bottle and injected into the cartridge
once placed in the e-plex instrument the
test takes about an hour and a half
the last rapid identification method we
will discuss and the main focus of my
talk today
is the broker mbt sexy typer this method
utilizes the multi-toff technology and
has the potential to identify any
organism that is contained in the
broker multitap database identifications
may be batched or performed individually
when performing a cost analysis of
different rapid identification methods
the sepsi typer was least expensive for
us
before we talk more about the sepsi
typer let's review the theory behind the
multitop method
multitof is an acronym for matrix
assisted laser desorption ionization
time of flight
it uses mass spectrometry that was
initially used in microbiology to
identify organisms growing on a culture
plate
to perform the identification from a
culture plate the organism
is inoculated to the target plate as
shown here in the direct method the
organisms
is placed directly onto the plate
depending on the organism it may be
necessary to use the extended direct
method
which uses formic acid to break down the
cell wall prior to inoculating the
target
organisms with a thick cell wall may
require an extraction prior to
inoculating the plate
once the organism dries on the target
plate a matrix is added which absorbs
the irradiation of the
laser and helps the ionization of the
particles the target plate is then
placed into the instrument
once a target plate is in the instrument
a laser is emitted
that will strike the organism well on
the plate
this causes two things to occur the
organism is vaporized
and the particles that are created are
ionized giving them a positive
charge
these charged particles are then
accelerated toward
a detector plate by the the potential
difference between the target and the
electrodes
the mass and charge of the particles
determine how long it takes for them to
hit the detector plate
as a result small particles with a small
mass hit the detector plate first and
larger particles
followed behind this is known as a time
of flight or tof
as the particles hit the detector plate
the time of flight and
the intensity are measured for each
particle size and the data is
plotted on a chart the x-axis is the
mass
charge and it is plotted from the
smallest to the largest
the y-axis is the intensity and is
determined by the number of particles of
a particular
size the greater the number of particles
the higher the peak
in the multitop software there is a
spectral data for
hundreds of different organisms for each
species there are multiple spectra this
allows various strains
of the same species to be identified you
can see from the spectral data shown
here that each species
has its own unique pattern based upon
the particle size
and intensity the multi-top software
uses an algorithm to calculate
a multi-tough biotype or score
this score is determined by comparing
the number of peaks of the unknown
sample
with the number of peaks of organisms in
the spectral library
in addition the intensity of the peaks
are factored into this calculation
once a score is obtained it can be used
to determine the probability of a
correct identification
a score of 2.0 to 3.0 is a high
confidence identification and may be
reported with
the genus and species 1.7 to 1.999
is a low confidence score the genus in
this score range is usually accurate
but the species is questionable scores
below
1.7 is a low score and does not provide
an adequate identification
broker has developed a blood culture
rapid identification kit
based upon the multitop technology known
as the mbt
sepsi diaper this kit allows for
identification of blood culture isolates
directly from a positive blood culture
50 identifications can be performed from
one kit
and the shelf life is up to 24 months
and may be stored at room temperature
there's a dedicated software module that
is loaded onto the multitop instrument
that is used specifically for the sepsi
type for kit testing
this is a dedicated software
and in this software the mass range that
is used for the identification
is slightly more narrow when compared to
the regular multi-soft software
the reason for this slight restriction
is that there
are multiple peaks that are found in the
lower mass range that are due to blood
cells in the sample
you will also notice from the chart that
the mbt scores
for acceptable identification are lower
the reason for the lower score
thresholds are due to
unwanted peaks that are found throughout
the mass range when using the sepsi
typer
as a result there is a bit more
variation between the library spectra
and the sepsi type spectra producing a
lower score
to perform an identification using the
sepsi diaper there is
some sample preparation that must be
occur first one mill of the blood is
removed from the positive bottle and
placed on in a conical tube
lysis buffer is added and mixed for 10
seconds the sample is then centrifuged
for two minutes
and the supernatant is discarded after
adding a wash buffer the sample is mixed
again
and centrifuged for one minute the
supernatant is discarded and some of the
pellet is
transferred to two spots on the target
plate formic acid is added to one of the
spots
and then both spots are allowed to dry a
matrix is placed on each of the spots
and allowed to dry the sample is now
ready to be placed into the instrument
and to be tested
if no identification is obtained an
extraction may be required in order to
get an identification
the extraction causes disruption of the
cell wall of the organism prior to
putting it on
the target plate
when we made our decision to try sepsi
type a validation was completed prior to
implementation
we tested 106 positive blood cultures
using both the sepsi typer and
traditional
identification methods such as a micro
scan and staph latex
we compared the identification obtained
from the sepsi typer to the
identification from the traditional
methods
an acceptable identification was
obtained on 82 percent of the isolates
no identification was obtained on 18
percent of the isolates
three of these organisms had no peaks
which indicated there was
no particles hitting the target plate
and 16 had low scores
the lack of identification may have been
due to technologist technique
or to low level bacteremia during our
testing we noticed that e coli
were identified as as equalized shigella
the protein structure of these two
organisms are so similar that it's not
possible to separate them using the
moldy tof
we also had one culture that contained
two organisms
escherichia coli and pseudomonas
originism
in this case the most predominant
organism e coli was identified
here's a list of the organisms that we
tested along with a number of isolates
of each
the left side shows the organisms that
were identified to the species level
while the right side shows the organisms
that were identified to the genus level
this chart lists the organisms that did
not produce an identification
and you can notice that some of these
organisms are slow growers or anaerobes
and or that sometimes will produce a
not much growth in a blood culture
bottle
during our validation study one thing
became very obvious
technologist technique matters when
initially starting our validation we
tested 29 samples
during this pre-validation phase 55
percent of the organisms did not achieve
an identification
we did not feel that we could proceed
with this level of performance
however during this time one of our
technologists who had a molecular
background
was being trained to notice that the
technique being used to remove the
supernatant
was not protecting the organism pellet
she suggested a minor modification and
technique
based upon her molecular experience that
resulted in a significant
improvement in the number of
identifications since our validation we
have also noticed that technologist
variation still occurs
if you intend to use a sepsi typer you
should plan to monitor success rates of
each employee
and retrain when you know that an
employee is not achieving a standard
identification rate
once we saw that the sepsi typer worked
well in our laboratory we implemented
the test using this algorithm
we first perform a gram stain subculture
the bottle to solid medium
and call the critical value if multiple
blood cultures are positive
we perform the sepsi typer on the first
positive set only
after discussing this new technology
with our infectious disease physicians
and explaining the process of testing we
decided to
run the sepsis piper twice per shift
and also to add comments which will
discuss in a minute
when appropriate when the subsidy typer
is done we notify the pharmacy for
the appropriate hospital and then they
will review the patient's chart
and if it looks like an antibiotic may
need to be changed based upon this
identification the pharmacy contacts
physician the traditional susceptibility
is then performed
one of the key pieces to our algorithm
is notification of the pharmacy
so that immediate action can be taken
studies have shown that if rapid
identification
rapid identification methods are
utilized without a process to take
immediate action
the value of the rapid testing is
diminished
the comments that we attached to the
sepsi type of report
are listed here since we started the
sepsi typer with the investigational use
kit
we added a comment in indicating such
when an identification of e coli is
obtained we report the second comment
since e coli is the is a common organism
found in the bloodstream
and shigella is rarely isolated it
seemed reasonable to let the physicians
know that it is likely an e coli
during the validation one beta strip did
not match the landsfield group of the
traditional methods
so we when we get a beta strap
identification we wait for the
traditional identification to report the
landfill group and report
the third comment maldi also cannot
distinguish between
strep pneumoniae and strep midas when we
get one of these identifications we
report the last comment
we compared the time frame for obtaining
the identification and susceptibility of
a blood culture isolate
when using the sepsi type or compared to
the traditional methods there's a
significant difference in the
identification portion
but no significant difference for the
susceptibility
once the identification is complete the
institutional
biogram can be used to adjust the
therapy when necessary
when using sepsi type or this can occur
one to two days earlier
than when using traditional methods
now i'd like to discuss a couple of case
studies to show how sepsis hyper has
improved case
patient care our first study is a 77
year old female who is admitted
to the hospital for weakness and failure
to thrive
blood cultures were collected in the
emergency room and vancomycin and
peptidase of actin were started
empirically
on the first day of hospitalization the
blood cultures were positive for
gram-positive cocci
that are seen here in this grain stain
the sepsis diaper kit results identified
the organism as an enterococcus
specialist
which was reported to the pharmacist who
is part of the antimicrobial stewardship
team
and an infectious disease physician was
consulted which immediately stopped the
vancomycin and piptazo
after 24 hours
based on the local antibiogram
ampicillin and gentamicin were initiated
and in order for a transesophageal
echocardiography was
ordered or a tt or tee on the second day
of hospitalization the tee
was performed which revealed a large
vegetation on the mitral valve
the patient was evaluated by the cardiac
surgeon
on the day of the tee which recommended
medical management only the patient was
given six weeks of ampicillin
and digentamiacin without issue
the second case is a 41 year old male
with a complicated and prolonged
hospitalization
that followed an abdominal surgery he
had developed
fever and an elevated white blood cell
count on hospital day 21.
his pick line had been present since
admission
blood cultures were collected and
vancomycin ceftriaxone
and fluconazole were started empirically
on hospital day 22 blood cultures were
positive for gram-negative rods
and the sepsi type were demonstrated
intraobactor cloachie
the antimicrobial strip ship team was
notified
if the fluconazole and vancomycin were
discontinued based upon the grain stain
and the sepsi type of results
the antimicrobial stewardship team
noticed that three months prior
neurobacteric was found in the urine
culture of of the patient
and so they recommended changing the
ceftriaxone to
maripenum while sensitivity results were
pending
microscan results available on the
hospital day
24 confirmed that the enterobacter was a
cell triaxial resistance strain
and therapy with maripenum was continued
for 10 days this picc line was exchanged
and the patient responded well
therapy
reimbursement for sepsi type intestine
is dependent upon the structure of your
laboratory
payment for testing on many hospitalized
patients is included as part of the
drg reimbursement that hospitals receive
for patient care
for commercial labs there are several
codes that may be used to receive
payment since i'm not a billing expert i
can't recommend
codes for your lab but i can tell you
what we do we use the codes listed here
to build for organism identification
and since there's a concentration
procedure that is being used to prepare
your sample for testing
we bill and receive payment for that
concentration step
before implementing the use of the sepsi
type we performed a cost analysis
to see how it would compare to other
methods we perform about sixty thousand
blood filters each year
with eleven percent positivity rate that
means we have about sixty
six hundred positive or cultures per
year since most patients have multiple
blood cultures drawn
and often both are positive we perform
substitutes on about half
or 3 300 blood cultures each year we
estimated that the multiplex pcr panel
costs about 105 dollars
and the cost of the multiplex testing
would be
almost three hundred fifty thousand
dollars per year the cost of the sepsi
typer is about nine dollars and fifty
cents each
each each year the sepsi type of cost
would be
almost sixty three thousand dollars in
addition it's more time consuming
to perform the sexy typer when compared
to a multiplex pcr assay
i estimated that i needed to add an
additional 0.6 fte in order to perform
this testing
the difference in detect time expenses
between
performing the multiplex pcr and
performed its sepsi typer
was about thirty eight thousand dollars
per year when you
subtract the cost of the sepsi type or
kits and the tech time from the cost of
the multiplex pcr panels
the sepsi typer was about 250 thousand
dollars
less expensive than the multiplex pcr
assays
we found the sepsi type provides rapid
results that allow the physician to
adjust therapy up to 48
hours earlier than traditional methods
earlier de-escalation
or administration of targeted
antibiotics can be accomplished when the
identification
is reported earlier and can also result
in a change from
iv antibiotics to oral drugs these
factors result
in improved patient care reduced length
to stay in the hospital
and the associated costs with that
physicians have been very satisfied with
the ability to obtain rapid blood
culture identifications
the chairman of the antimicrobial
stewardship program
dr steve burdette indicated that the use
of the sepsi typer has allowed him to
adjust therapy quicker
at times this has resulted in narrowing
the therapy and at other times it
has allowed him to escalate to more
appropriate antibiotics
the physicians have become so accustomed
to getting these rapid results
that we have to inform them each time we
have multitop maintenance
so they understand why they're not
getting their results as usual
in closing copy net is currently using a
research use
only sepsi type of product but we plan
to move to the fda approved version as
soon as possible
since it is an ruo assay we developed
and validated our own protocols for
in-house testing
i'd like to thank you for your attention
and would be happy to entertain
questions at this time
thank you ike for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay so let's get started let's try
again our first question ike
is um could you quickly please review
the
no id results on slide 27
what exactly is included in
in this category
so the organisms that we did not get an
identification on are listed on this
slide
and you you will notice that these
organisms are
some of them are anaerobes and
lactobacillus is an organism that tends
to grow
slowly in the blood culture bottles
strep pneumo is also an
organism that we know that doesn't
always grow very well in a blood culture
bottle
and so these were not really surprising
to me
some of the ones that i was a little
surprised about was a coagulation
negative staff
however if you have a low-level
bacteremia
you you may not get an identification on
these and the reason for that is when
you
are processing your sample you're trying
to create a pellet of the
of the organism and so if you have just
a very small amount of the organism
present
you may not be able to get a good uh
graft to be able to compare to the
library and so
what we did find though is that when we
got an identification it was an accurate
identification we did not have
problems with getting a wrong
identification so
multi and this is true when we're doing
sepsi type or just
identifications from a auger plate we
either get a good identification or we
just don't get an identification at all
and
and so in my opinion that's what i
prefer is to not get an identification
than to get a wrong identification
is this currently fda cleared
on the uh brook or maldi
it is not an fda cleared process or a
kit we use it's a
research use only kit and we have
validated it in our laboratory for this
testing
and so um we when we did our validation
study we looked at the organisms that
are the most common things that we see
in our blood cultures
and we did a validation to be able to
allow us to be able to identify them
based upon our information here and so
my understanding is there is an fda
approved kit that's
that's in the works but it's not
available yet
thank you um our next question is
um did you put microbes in the maldi tof
uh with buffer or with menia well you
actually take media from the bottle
uh from your possible culture bottle and
and put it into your
do the sample processing step in order
to get your repellative organism
for validation can you use
blood culture uh aliquip at
uh negative 80 degrees within eight
hours of being
unloaded from blood culture instruments
well we did not try that so i'm not sure
what uh what effect the that would have
on these organisms of course you know
when you freeze organisms that can
uh kind of damage them a little bit and
uh
so it may be possible we just didn't try
that when we did our validation study
okay uh the next question is exactly
what technique was changed when removing
the supernatant to protect the pellet
so one of the things we found that when
we did our initial training of our
technologists is that they were uh
going in with the pipette tip and and
trying to suck out the supernatant
and we found that some of the
technologists were
actually sucking the pellet of the
organism out of the bottom of the
the tube and so when we had our
technologists that had the molecular
diagnostic experience
being trained she noticed that that was
that that was a real potential
and she suggested that we would when we
put our
tubes into our microcentrifuge tube that
we make sure that we
place them in a certain way and that
when we
and of course when you spin them down
these micro centrifuge tubes they're at
an
angle and so your pellet kind of goes up
on the side of the tube
well she suggested that whenever you
take off your supernatant that you go in
there with your pipette
on the other side of the tube so that
you're not disturbing that pellet that's
present there
and so we made that minor change and it
had
significant uh impact and improvement in
our
results
very powerful presentation how well did
your staff
seem to adapt to the change in workflow
uh well it um it took us a little while
to get people
used to this and but they found fairly
quickly that they could get these
results out to the
physicians quickly and they were happy
about that
now it does take a little bit of time we
we do six batches a day we do two
batches of testing on each shift
uh including third shift and
and it takes about 20 minutes to do that
the process of
processing samples now uh keep in mind
we do about 5 000 blood cultures a month
and so
a lot of times we're testing we're we're
processing 10 to 12
15 samples at a time and so it takes
about 20 minutes to do that
the processing step and then um
then we put it on the maldi tof and so
we actually made some adjustments in our
workflow
in order to have a person that was
designated
just to do multi-top and that actually
was something that we did when we first
got our our
multi-top instrument we noticed that in
order to really use this effectively we
really needed to change our workflow
from the normal processes that we have
been using so we
adjusted things in to allow this one
technologist to be able to
um to just
focus on this on this and so when we did
that
it created less stress for the employees
and
they they seem to respond very well to
it and it's also
made it easier sometimes if you have if
you have multiple people that you're
trying to train at one
point you know if you get a new
technologist it takes a little while to
train them to do plate reading
and so if you have someone that's
training on plate reading you want to
train someone on something
different this is a good bench and it's
fairly easy for a new technologist to
come in and learn and so it's
they've actually responded very well to
this and and have done
very well but being able to get these
results out in a timely manner
did you face any resistance among the
physicians
regarding providing an id without the
susceptibility results uh well we are
providing a susceptibility result but
it's
you know it's in the normal time frame
that they get the results uh actually
our physicians were the ones who
drove a lot of the interest in this they
the antibiotic stewardship committee was
looking at ways to decrease the or to
change the antibiotics to make sure the
patient gets on the appropriate
antibiotics
more quickly and so they were all for
this i mean they were
they were really interested in us coming
up with some other some method to
get a rapid identification and in fact
uh we
actually looked at several different
methods and
we were getting ready to go to go with
another method instead of this
but then when we realized that we were
our multi-top had been approved for in
the budget
and that we were going to have this we
decided that we're just going to wait
and not go with this other method
because it had limited number of
organisms that we could identify
and with the multi-top like i mentioned
you would be able to
identify essentially any organism that's
in the multi
tops database
there are no resistant gene markers that
can be detected by this method
what does your anti-microbial steward
stewardship committee's thoughts about
that
well we we've talked about that
particular issue and we've
uh we've tried to decide what would be
the best option for us and so
the the organism that they seem to be
most concerned about
is mrsa and being able to detect that
mri say
uh on these positive blood cultures and
of course mri says
you know one or staph aureus is one of
the uh
very common organisms that we see in
blood cultures and so
um we when i we did some other methods
that we did in addition to the multi-top
to help us get that mrsa result and so
uh what we do
is we take a an aliquot from our sample
our blood culture sample and
there's a couple different methods uh
that are out there
that they're rapid identification
methods that will identify the organism
plus give you the resistance genes we
were using one method
to do this one manufacturer and that
manufacturer went out of business but
so we stopped doing it for a while and
we're ready to start that back up again
but
this by taking the blood culture from
these uh bottles we can do this rapid
identification test that will give us
like that
that identification in the resistance
mechanism
in addition to that and so we decided
that that would be the best way to go
for the staph aureus because it allows
us to do that
additional testing just for the the
blood cultures have staff for us now
for the gram negatives you know that's a
little bit of more of an issue
and we are looking at some other
alternatives for that that will
i think down the road that will help us
with that to be able to give a more
rapid identity or susceptibility
or the resistance markers for those
we have a lot of questions coming in our
next question is
is there a difference in performance
with different
blood culture media
well since we're going to use one media
we well
actually that's that's actually not true
when we uh
started doing this we acquired some
other hospitals and they were using a
different blood culture media a
different
blood culture system and so when we did
our validation studies
when we got these new instruments we had
to do another validation study for the
other type of media and we really didn't
see any
really any difference between the
different medias what we did see
is the difference though and the
performance from one technologist to the
other
and so it is important like i mentioned
in the presentation that
if you are going to use this the the
sexy typer
that you do probably want to monitor
your performance of your technologist
we we have some technologists that have
very few
uh no ids or no peaks and but then we
have other technologists that
they're you know they're much higher and
so when we see that kind of thing we
want to make sure that
we do a proper training and to make sure
that we
the technologists are following our
protocols and and also
learn the techniques of not sucking that
pellet out of there in order to get a
good identification
uh thank you ike our next question
let's see we have so many uh what about
the sensitivity or
specificity specificity
uh did you validate against traditional
culture
do you still are you still doing
cultures as a backup
well the this identification method is
from a culture so you're you're not
replacing the culture you're just doing
a rapid identification from that culture
and so you still have your blood culture
bottle you still do so
you do your gram stain you subculture
your bottles and those types of things
for us we do the grain stain we get that
results to the physicians immediately
with
as a critical value and then we do the
sepsi type or since we're only doing
that
a couple of times a shift we need to
make sure that uh
that they're getting that identification
so uh and
and then we have to have an organism on
a plate in order to
to do the susceptibility testing so we
are continuing to do a routine blood
culture
we're just adding this additional piece
in there to help us get a quicker
identification
and then the physicians can use that
information to
adjust their therapy when it's
appropriate
thank you mike our next question is that
20 minute processing step uh per sample
or per batch
that's a per batch and uh one other
thing too with with our
method that we're currently using uh
this was the initial
protocol that we developed but uh now
there's a a more rapid
streamlined uh protocol that we've
actually validated
that but we just haven't put into place
yet and then we'll actually stream it
will
streamline it just a little bit and
probably reduce that processing time by
about five minutes
or so our next question
how often did you need to perform the
extraction method
actually we we don't usually perform the
extraction method
uh you know we're since we have a
culture that we're working with
we can get an identification usually the
next day if we need to do that
you know the the main goal here is to
get a rapid identification if you have
to go through that extraction process it
takes a little bit longer
and our physicians didn't feel like that
was necessary and
um so i mean that's what it says in your
pro and the procedure
the package insert from the kit but we
don't typically use that and so
um but
you know if you look at the organisms
that might that we isolated
i would we would not normally need to do
that extraction method based upon the
organisms that were isolated from our
blood cultures
mike have you seen any false positive
results
i'm not sure what they mean by false
positive results but
um we haven't found that that has given
us organisms that
um were given this wrong information if
that's what the question was
um you know we know that that we're not
going to pick up everything
because of the the sometimes the
technique of the technologists or these
low bacteremias
but we haven't really found anything
where i thought where i considered a
false positive result
okay um i apologize if i mispronounced
this word
uh the next question is how do the rates
of identification
using the steps a typer
compare to those when using the
multiplex
pcr
uh i'm sorry did it say the rates of the
of the identification yes the rates of
the identification
okay so uh it's it's actually fairly
similar when you look at the
list of organisms that i showed on my uh
powerpoint
uh those 10 or so organisms were
account for about 75 percent of our
organisms that we see
and so each of the multiplex pcr assays
have a list of organisms that they
can identify and so as long as you're
you know you have a little bit more
sensitivity with the pcr test because
you're
doing pcr and um
but if you if your organism doesn't fall
into that database then you're
not able to identify it with the sepsi
typer you have the ability the
possibility of identifying pretty much
anything that's in their database
and so the rates are fairly similar
with your detection of or getting an
identification
what is the lowest acceptable score you
use as an acceptable id
well uh we have a if you look at the
slide that
let me see if i can find that slide here
the slide that gives you the
the scores so um
that score let's see it's a one it's
one point 1.79
is what we've considered a low positive
result and
when we get anything below a 1.8 i'm
sorry 1.6 is
is the lowest possible score that would
be used for an identification so 1.6 to
1.79
we could identify those organisms to
genius level and report the genus
in order to give us to be able to give
an identification we would need to have
a 1.8 or higher
thank you mike do you have any data from
pharmacies such as savings and
antibiotic days
antibiotic cost or length of stay
that data is extremely difficult to
to come by you have to do fairly
extensive studies
and we
we haven't been we haven't actually
collected that data but we did
we have had a number of antidotal uh
type of scenarios where we've been able
to show that you know this really did
improve the patient care
they were able to change their
antibiotics uh appropriately and really
when you can look at the cost of this
compared to you know
one of the things that you're concerned
about is a return on investment
basically
and if you look at the cost of doing a
multi-top
sepsi typer um it's really not very
expensive and so
if you could do a test that cost less
than ten dollars and can
even affect a few patients that's
probably going to have a fairly big
impact on
the cost or at least make it equal now
if you're looking at your multiplex pcrs
those are fairly expensive tests and so
you probably need to have a little bit
more data i guess to back you up
when when we started doing this we had
already had the multi-top
available in our laboratory we didn't
buy the multi-soft to do this
but we already had it here and so we
felt like that we could do a fairly
inexpensive test
that would give us some rapid
identifications and and so
um we didn't really feel like it that it
was really necessary to
do a full study to to get that
information that would be great to be
able to have that information
but we just don't have that at this
point
we have so many questions coming in and
um we have time for just a few more
i want to remind our audience that the
questions we were unable to answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period
will be answered by ike using the email
address that you provided
at the time of registration so let's
squeeze in a few more questions
our next question is what was the
adjustment
that your molecular specialist
recommended
that resulted in more successful testing
i think i already answered that question
but it's just the method that we use to
pull the supernatant off making sure we
weren't disturbed
disturbing the pellet
did you look at the micro bacterial
or ssba organisms
i'm not sure what that question means if
it's
mycobacterial questions okay for our
blood cultures we did not
we have validated the mycobacterial
organisms on our
when we're doing routine cultures and
we are using that to do mycobacterial
identifications we haven't really
uh used it for our blood cultures and of
course you don't get very many positive
mycobacterium
on your your blood cultures but but
when we've ident used it for our routine
cultures we do see that
it works we get identification correct
identifications from it
was a verification required for each of
your blood culture bottle types or in
multiple
uh facilities yes so uh all of our
all of our blood cultures are sent to
one location the bottles are sent here
we felt like that and that was a big big
discussion about whether we should keep
them at the sites or to
have them all sent to one place and we
felt like that we made
uh delayed them getting an incubator but
on the back side we had more
opportunities in the core laboratory
setting
uh to be able to uh bring them all here
and
and have more um things that we could do
in the core lab so but since we did have
two different blood culture systems that
we were using at the time
we did have to validate each blood
culture system to make sure that they
worked with this
and since they were all being done here
in one laboratory
we didn't have to of course validate for
each of the individual hospitals
thank you ike do hospitals use the
technology
as often as a clinical diagnostic
well i'm not sure exactly what that
question means but i can tell you that
we do
use this on all of our blood cultures
from all the hospitals and
so when the blood culture comes in we
will
and that's positive we're going to run
it regardless of which hospital is from
and and we run it on all of our positive
patients we don't run it on every single
sample
so if we have two two sets of blood
cultures that have
grab negative basal light we're going to
only run it on one of those
and and and
we also if we have a blood culture that
has two organisms on the gram stain
we do not use the multi-top for that
typically
thank you mike what percentage of your
positive blood
culture showed the organisms had a
restraint marker present
well since we're not using any resi
we're not using an assay that uses a
resist
or detects for resistance markers
we we don't have that now we like i said
we have tesla
our staff fouries but we're using a
different test to do that
okay can you please explain again the
difference
between the standard and mbt
sets the typer software so there's a
there's a specific software that you can
use for the
for the sepsi diaper you have your
standard software that you use for your
bacterial cultures and
and uh but when you do the sepsi taper
you are processing a blood sample
and so in in addition to having your
organism present there
you've got particles of life blood cells
that are present in your sample
and when you have that you're going to
does those
red blood cells produce small particles
that are going to be
go through your detect up to your
detector plate and be detected there
and you'll see little peaks from those
particles
and so the sepsi type for software uh
the mbt
sepsis type software actually kind of
the it
kind of gets rid of those the lower
level of the spectra
then and then you will see some
additional
particles uh that that are from your
blood
uh in the other the higher specters of
your
of your uh graph but the the sepsis type
of software
kind of helps to to weed out some of
those and it
lo actually lowers the score that you
need to get a good identification
because of those uh life blood cell
particles and things that you see from
your blood culture bottle
thank you we have time today for one
more question
and our uh final question is
is this something that you would
recommend for a lab
that gets few positive culture bottles a
day
well if you have a moldy tof you know
a multisoft has a very expensive
instrument and if you have
a multi-top for using for identifying
your
blood cultures or your routine cultures
uh organisms from there
it's really a simple process to do this
and so
um you know it may be cost prohibitive
to if you have just very few
cultures uh to purchase a maldi tof and
and to do this but
like i said if you already have a
multi-top in place it's really not a
real expensive test and and it's
an easy process and i think that you
will see some impact from your
the patient care perspective by using
this type of technology
thank you so much uh ike do you have any
final comments for our audience today
well i would like to thank everyone for
listening for uh
for all the questions there's lots of
them here still that didn't get answered
i'd like to thank you for your attention
and uh you know we've
used the maldi tof and and the sepsis
diaper for several years
we've been extremely happy with it and
feel like that it's been a good
move in our laboratory to help improve
patient care
thank you again ike for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
brooker daltonix for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
again questions that we did not have
time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
we would once again like to thank mr ike
northern
for his time today and his important
research we would like to thank lab
roots and again
our sponsor brooker daltonix for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
today's live event until next time
goodbye everyone